Manette is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina
hi Manette how are you hi Dave thank you
for taking my call sure what's up I have
a question about the baby steps my
husband and I are 51 and 52 and we our
own baby step - we've paid off about
13,000 in the last year good for you um
thank you our our situation is a little
different our mortgage is one of our
lower we only owe $11,000 on our
mortgage but we owe about 41 on loans
credit cards medical and my car and how
much of that is your car 15 okay and
what's your household income
seventy-five good okay so what you're
telling me is fifty two thousand dollars
and you're a hundred percent debt-free
house and everything no there's one more
thing we have I have a school loan that
is sixty eight thousand and it's in
forbearance so I know so I'm not sure
how to handle all that do I just stay in
the baby sense because we're really
fattening retirement okay okay all right
that we're still holding off time yeah
but but you're gonna have to really get
with it all right I mean you guys you
don't need to be inside of a restaurant
less you're working there I don't know
you don't need to be talking about a
vacation I'm not you you have a mess yes
we have a huge mess so you have a
hundred thousand dollars to pay off
making seventy five thousand so if you
use thirty three thousand to do that
it's going to take you three years to
clean this up you're going to be 56 all
right and then you're going to start
retirement here's the thing Matt even
though that is strenuous it is still the
shortest path to retirement wealth
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is now going out the door
for all these payments well and you have
to clear these payments in order to be
able to have the juice the mathematical
juice to hit retirement in the mouth and
build it up and you know you got then
from 56 to 66 you got 10 years to really
pour into retirement and play
ketchup and you'll be able to do that
because the good news is your house is
going to be paid off in that process -
yeah and so you're going to hit you're
going to hit retirement with a paid for
house easily and you're going to be a
hundred percent debt-free and whatever
investing we can build up in about a ten
year period of time if you guys bust it
for the next three years and knock this
out is that logical yes yeah that is now
we're going to be in Charlotte doing our
very first toad a smart money event ever
in Charlotte October the fourth Rachel
Cruise my daughter and I would you and
your husband like to come as my guests
oh my goodness that would be awesome
thank you so much we would love to have
you there you hold on and we'll have
Kelly pick up and we'll give you some
tickets and give you some of the further
information and inspiration because you
just need you need this I coming to the
pep rally right before the game because
you're getting ready to engage in the
game and go for it and you can really do
this it's going to be awesome so thank
you hold on Kelly we'll pick up and
we'll get you guys signed up for that
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or a five hundred thousand dollar
income
you